That's whenever being a crazy
became the socially acceptable thing to do. And now everybody's
a crazy
>> It became socially acceptable to be a complete I'm speaking
directly from
I don't care. You don't have to debate me. I just don't like
that people can live in their own little media bubbles. I know
he's going to make this argument that like well, you know, I
react to stuff online, but it's different. It's more sanitized
that way. It doesn't really prove like we've seen enough examples
on my stream. Asmongold has probably seen enough examples of
me doing this on my stream where somebody can make a video or
whatever the [__] else and it kind of sort of seems
like they know what they're talking about. And then in an actual
conversation where they have to defend their opinions, you find
out oh [__] this guy doesn't know [__]
all about what he's supposedly
you know, made some video about.
The whole point of the I'm just I'm really critical of all the
people that are like, you know, market marketplace of ideas,
marketplace of ideas. We need to have an open marketplace of
ideas. Like if that's true,
the ideas have to like clash with each other, right? That marketplace
implies like some amount of like flow between different areas.
Not everybody releases whatever slop they want onto the internet
on their own corner that's algorithmically reinforcing reinforcing
whatever view they have and there's like no contact made with
anybody else at the end of the day. Now, hold on. We had the
Asmongold response really quick to some of those Destiny tweets,
some of those Destiny responses. All right? We had an Asmongold
response to that. Let's go. Destiny mad about Oh, no. Oh, no.
Oh, here we go.
The He's mad again? Jesus.
I don't care. You don't have to debate
He's mad again? What is he mad about What is he mad about?
What did I do?
This guy's always mad about something.
anybody I just don't like that people can live in their own little
media bubbles. I know he's going to make this argument that like
well, you know, I react to stuff online, but it's different.
It's more sanitized that way. It doesn't really prove like we've
seen enough examples on my prove anything because you're not
doing it the way I want you to. Oh, okay. Well, that how convenient
for you.
Asmongold has probably seen enough examples of me doing this
on my stream where somebody can make a video or whatever the
[__] else and it kind of sort of seems like they
know what they're talking about. And then in an actual conversation
where they have to defend their man. I
Destiny says this, but it's so funny,
Unironic I've started to get into the place in my head
where I am positive
that Destiny knows he doesn't do that well in debates and he
has focused so much on building a community that comes in and
sweeps after.
The Taylor Lorenz conversations went so horrendously for him
and I think that most people in his community believe he won
those conversations. They totally believe that Destiny is the
more informed intelligent person in those conversations and it's
insane.
It's insane to see. It's especially insane to see when he looks
like a complete [__] afterwards when he doesn't even
recognize the exact documentation he was looking at to argue
with Taylor Lorenz.
So, he lost both of those conversations and I'm convinced that
it's it's all about how his community comes in after the fact.
That's why he wants the the in-person conversations. One, he
is good at those at those conversations or the over voice conversations.
He's good at He gets a lot of updates from his community or arguments
from his community while he does those conversations. He's looking
at his chat a lot. Okay? And then they can always so sort of
go and sweep after the fact. Because it's happening on the fly,
nobody gets time to think about what they're saying. They can
basically find something to criticize always. They can find some
way to make him the winner in any on the fly conversation. But
if it's if it's not that, if it's asynchronous, I do think that
he loses that ability and he is far less effective an arguer.
So,
I think this is like kind of fine for Asmongold. I don't believe
Asmongold would actually if there was really good substantive
criticism, I don't know that he would go and deal with it.
But I he's pointing something out that is true that it's like
oh, I don't want to do it the exact way that you'd be really
good at. No, I don't want to do that. No, thank you. opinions.
You find out oh [__] this guy doesn't know [__]
all about what he's supposedly
you know, made some video about. The whole point of the I'm just
I'm really critical of all the people that are like, you know,
I think it's just true that Destiny's taking a lot of people
who are factually
and he has essentially manufactured a way to make them look stupid.
That he will talk to them and eventually he'll, you know, be
like kind of irritating to the point that they'll say something,
they'll get a little hyperbolic, and he'll do his like sperg
he he'll do his total like sperg out over it, right?
Right? And then that'll be the clip. That'll be what goes forward
in time.
It's like, yeah, but I don't think all of those people weren't
knowledgeable.
They might not be the best at getting their thoughts out in like
a debate, but they're nowhere near as dumb as like Destiny's
community tries to make them seem. That's all they're all just
achieving a political goal when they do that. Anyways, anyway,
let's keep listening to Asmongold. marketplace of ideas, marketplace
of ideas. We need to have an open marketplace of ideas. Like
we have it right now, by the way. Like I'm I'm literally listening
to your feedback and your criticism at this very moment.
The ideas have to like clash with each other, right? It has to
be the way I want it to be because I think that will be more
advantageous for me. Of course. Marketplace implies like some
amount of like flow between different areas. Not everybody releases
whatever slop they want onto the internet on their own corner
that's algorithmically reinforcing reinforcing whatever view
they have and there's like no Why is he mad again? People want
that because they know that I have a big audience and they think
that if they can like catch me in something like I didn't expect
or something like that or like catch me off guard with something,
it will make them look good. I never operate outside of my own
frame. I don't. Why would I do something that could put what
I do at risk for any degree? Why would I do that at all? Why
would I do something whenever I know that my method of doing
this is already What Why would I ever take something that could
potentially not go the way I want it to? Why would I ever do
that? Uh so, he's he's like
totally forfeiting or totally giving saying yes. Like obviously,
I don't want to do a debate cuz it could make me look bad. Of
course, I'm not going to do that. Right? Pretty gay? Well, I
mean, most people will make this decision.
I think as long as he's willing to take criticism, like real
criticism and incorporate it in,
like there's something to be said here,
I think when you get to this scale, you also probably can't get
criticism in very well.
But I've seen times where like there's enough pushback, he can
end up in a conversation with somebody. I don't think he'll ever
do with Destiny, but he ended up in a conversation with Hasan
like a year and a half ago, right? Was it September 2025?
2024 maybe? September 2024?
Around that time.
So, he ended up in that conversation with Hasan. Now, the thing
about debates is especially if you don't do them very often,
you can be caught off guard. You can like misstep in a situation
and it doesn't mean you're not correct or don't know the answer.
You could you could legitimately just misstep in a conversation,
right? You could totally forget for a mill for like a a couple
seconds an argument that you should have
So, it's not really the best debates or at least like a a public
debate especially if something in VC especially if it's not,
you know, planned
Right? Like I would say it's a little different for like planned
accepted debates where you go in and you have all the talking
points you want to do. That's maybe not as as different, but
if if somebody's just calling you out and you they want to debate
you right now, like they could just forget something they should
say, right? My mindset and everything that I do is based around
outcomes. I don't care like what people think about me. I don't
care about any of that. I care about basically achieving a goal.
That's it. I don't care if if people Oh, it's it's not fair cuz
X Y or Z. Who gives a [__]
Think whatever you want. Contact made with anybody else at the
end of the day. I don't care. You don't have to debate No, there's
no reason for me to do that. Why would I do it? It's not going
to happen. Uh I respond to people's opinions all the time. They
want to cry about it or get mad that I'm not doing it in the
way they want me to. Well, the reason why Here's the real reason
why they want me to. It's because they think that there is a
higher probability that I will look bad. Just based on the nature
of that argumentation,
why would I engage in something that they think would make me
look bad? Why Why would I do that? Why would I intentionally
do something
There are pros and cons, but talking live about a topic does
test your ideas in a way react exception doesn't. No, it doesn't.
It literally doesn't. I'm sorry. It It actually doesn't. The
react exception stuff is actually better. I'm not even joking.
Like and the best thing you could do is
basically just writing text of responses.
Right?
Like something like a a message board like asynchronously responding
to each
That's the best way to argue. Gives people time to formulate
their arguments. Gives people time to make sure they're they're
saying what they want to say.
Asynchronous arguments are far better so long as one person isn't
leaving things
Right? They're far better for determining who's correct in a
situation. But what you have to do is if if you're going to if
you're going to want if you don't want to do this, if you want
to go and do this react back and forth, what you need to do is
react to everything they say or react to the entire point like
every substantive point. If you totally ignore the harshest the
the criticism that's most difficult to respond to, that needs
to be called out and then you're like a fraud. You're not trying
to do that. Yeah, you're not engaging in good faith in any way,
right? But the asynchronous thing is just objectively a better
way to have a conversation.
Or to find the truth at least.
But that's not really Destiny's goal. That's not really anybody's
goal who's trying to force a debate most of the time. I like
having debates. I like talking to people.
But for me, yeah, for me
I do think the asynchronous stuff is just better.
If you want to find out what the truth is. If you just want to
you know, have an argument, do some blood sports, do some entertainment,
live debating's way and more entertaining. Way way way way way
more
One person has a chance to really trip up and say something stupid
and totally themselves over.
But it doesn't mean that like
I don't know. I I assume
Here's how it would work where it would be fine. If you could
just retract things after you say them, if you could just go,
"Oh, yeah, I [__] up on this point." And and get
it fixed. But the problem is nobody's ever going to listen to
the retraction or how you're correcting the point, right? These
people all are all in their own hug boxes. They don't want to
be
Um so you could say that.
There's a problem because you can only really accept challenges
or you can only really talk with somebody if they're willing
to operate in good faith. And a lot of the people who say this,
who do this line of argumentation, these people are all in their
hug boxes, they don't want to be challenged. They will often
not engage in good faith. It's very rare that you'll find a person
who is willing to just have a conversation or a debate where
you're just trying to find the truth. That usually doesn't happen.
And like with Destiny, and honestly Destiny's perfectly capable
of having a good good faith conversation. I've watched him do
it before. But he's also from the internet blood sports era where
the whole point is to try to make your the other person trip
up and look
And he's perfectly capable of doing that, too. So obviously if
you're a big creator like Asmongold, you just wouldn't risk that.
That makes sense.
I do think he doesn't want to be challenged, but the core idea
he's going for here is not actually wrong. >> That would
potentially make me look that
Why would I do like yeah, exactly. Do they want a gotcha moment?
I don't think it'll I'm not saying that I would or not. I'm just
saying that like based off of their own reasoning, why would
I engage in something? Like that's the reason why they want to
do it. Obviously, duh. So no, why would I do that? Just based
off of the premise of it. And anyway, so that's really it. And
they want to yell and speak over you, feel like they're winning.
Well, I I don't listen. That that's all beside the point. The
simple reality is that I don't do it, that's it. And so you're
going to have to deal with it. That's the way it is. And cry
about it, about it, make another video, do another clip, whatever
you need to do to make yourself feel better. It's still nothing
going to change. Doesn't not debating make you look bad? Not
really. I mean like the people who think it makes it makes me
look bad See? If that voice crack happened in a debate, Asmongold
would be cooked. Minus 10,000 concurrent viewers.
Now he just gets to move past it, okay? No, there's nobody there
to start cackling at him. There's nobody there to go, "Holy,
your voice, you're so nervous. Oh my god, you can't even lie
to your audience with those your voice cracking. What a loser."
Right?
But there's nobody there to do that to you and farm clips out
of that, so actually it just works out fine for you. You just
voice crack a little bit, people laugh at you a little bit, and
you move on. Like a lot of people don't understand this because
they're not able to like parse out feedback. The majority of
those people are people that already don't like me. They said,
"Oh, this makes you look bad." You think I'm a Nazi. You think
I'm evil anyway. Like what do you mean it makes me look bad?
You already hate me. So the entire premise of this is based off
of a lie. So no
So what everyone's internal monologue is saying, though?
Maybe everyone's internal monologue is saying that, okay. Possibly.
Possibly.
But I don't know. It's less of an oral loss, okay? It's less
of an oral loss without somebody else there to laugh and make
it it put it in the person's face and possibly cause him to become
like, you know, emotionally dysregulated and then he says something
else stupid after that, right? Trying to recover from the
>> I'm this
This is not my first day on the internet, okay, guys? It's not
my first day. I I It This is so obvious. It's so obvious. How
do people not see this? Well, anyway, and they wouldn't care
either way. Exactly. It's It's completely clear. And I should
do it on talking while turns every time you talk. Yeah, I think
it'll be funny. 90% of every debate people who exactly looking
bad for. Well, I don't know. I mean I'm just saying in general,
that's that's the mindset. The people that are doing that, if
somebody Nobody This is what I've learned in like World of Warcraft.
Most of the time, the person who initiates a world PvP encounter
is the person who wins that encounter because they wouldn't have
initiated it unless they thought they could win. You see what
I'm saying?
People always have these instances [clears throat] where they're
going to do that. The Caleb thought you're on the right. Well,
I don't know what I don't know what he thought at all. You have
to ask him. And so that's it. But anyway, no, I'm not doing it,
it's too bad. You're going to You want to make another video
and I'll make another video and that's that's all you're going
to get. That lets us go into this Asmongold video, okay? We're
going to We're going to continue through the White House Correspondents
Dinner shooter stuff. So here we go. Assassination culture. That's
That's what I'm calling it.
Dude, there's no way.
You couldn't have fired up the camera and just been like, "Hey,
maybe I'll pick the massive
the flakes of dandruff out of my hair. Maybe I'll pick those
just ma
I'm going to zoom out. I It actually I usually do that sound
as a joke, but I
It's bad now. We could We couldn't just make sure those were
out? No?
How it's going to get a whole lot worse. I want to make this
video because in 2, 5, 3, 10 years from now, I want to be able
to go back to this video and say, "See, guys, I told you so."
And if I'm not right, I'm going to delete the video. So anyway,
this has been, I think, escalating. It's been going crazier and
crazier. We We've had now the third or fifth or I I lose count
how many attempts on Donald Trump's life. And so you have these
people that are doing this. And this is really really escalated
ever since, and I mean, let's guys, let's be honest here. It's
been escalating ever since BLM. That's whenever being a crazy
became the socially acceptable thing to do. And now everybody's
a crazy
And these are people who think that they're Dude. Actual mirror
posting from today. You love to see it. It's It became socially
acceptable to be a complete
And I'm I'm speaking directly from experience. Thank you. They're
fighting for civil rights. It's like, you know, you're not Rosa
Parks sitting at the front of the bus whenever you're burning
down Uber driver's Tesla because Elon Musk made you mad. You're
not fighting for civil rights, you're trying to take them away.
Everybody wants to have an election, you don't like the way it
turns out, time to burn everything down. Well, can you imagine
what would be like if everybody did this? Oh my god. It would
be crazy. And this is the form of third worldism. Everybody wants
to have an election, you don't like the way it turns out, time
to burn everything down. Well, can you imagine what would be
like if everybody did this? Oh my god. And this is the form of
third worldism. And I talk about this a lot. Well, I've still
on Twitch now. And I talk about this, though, because this is
the mentality of when the existing systems do not create the
outcome that you like, even though all of the systems are
Probably because Hasan hates America.
Yeah? Lots of people hate you. Do you know that it's your right
as an American to hate America?
You know that? That you're allowed freedom of speech, that's
your first amendment, right? It's the most important right you
have.
Did you know that that's allowed? Did you know that that's okay?
Are you not an American? Do you not believe in your Constitution?
I hope you are. I hope you do. >> It's not working properly,
you're being represented, you just simply don't have the numbers
to achieve your goals. Whenever this happens to you, the result
is not, "Well, I guess I have to work harder. I have to get more
people to agree with me." No, the result is, "Now I'm going to
set something on fire. I'm going to try to somebody. I'm going
to try to cause some sort of I'm going to stand, get this, guys.
I'm going to stand in the middle of the road
for Iran." Thank god. Thank god, that's going to save
Wait, did we get those? I know that people did that for Palestine.
Were people doing that over Iran? I haven't seen very many protests,
very many effective protests over Iran. But maybe it's been co-opted,
maybe it's like a no kings protest also was vaguely like
anti-Iran war. I'm not totally sure which one he's referring
to here. I feel like he's just re-adopting or repurposing the
Tom Cotton the original Tom Cotton Hasan
over Palestine, right? Where Tom Cotton says, "Run these people
down." And Hasan posts the Shinzo Abe assassination device. them.
Oh, for sure. Exactly. And if anything, it's going to make the
gas prices go even higher. So anyway, this is what I think is
happening. Is that people have socially normalized the act of
bad behavior, violence, aggression, hostility, and they've done
so with a righteous indignation that has enabled them to justify
doing so
as being the heroes of their own story. Is it too many Marvel
movies? I don't know, but it's too many something. Maybe it's
too many antidepressants.
Uh it's that this is the most compelling narrative that's ever
existed.
The little guy against the big guy is like the compelling narrative,
right? The underdog winning against all odds, that's always the
compelling story. That's why everybody paints themselves as a
rebellion or an uprising. That's why that's It's from the It's
like time It's uh from time immemorial, okay? That's the story
of Jesus, by the way. That he was working against the authorities
in the area, that he was just trying to spread the the gospel,
okay? Against the authorities in the area. He eventually is persecuted
and against all odds he ends up winning and founding his church.
It's It's like the oldest story that
Like is this guy mad about Star Wars that yeah, everybody paints
themselves that way. It's how everybody sees themselves when
they're when they feel any sense of injustice. That But a system,
there's something bigger pushing down on them. I have no idea,
but I know it's a big issue and I think I know where things are
going with this because we can't live in a society that's like
this. You can't have a society where people steal things, people
are being violent randomly, and people decide to kill elected
representatives. If you want a If you want a country like that,
go to Africa. There's plenty of them. They're called PvP servers.
I preferably don't want to be on one. So, these people are trying
to turn our normal I do agree with that. I think basically all
of those things are bad.
Yeah, I totally agree with all of that. Is there somebody who
Okay, well, I understand that the the arguments or the sort of
sweeping for the idea of possibly stealing is upsetting Destiny
Gold, but I don't know anybody who's openly just like
Yeah, stealing is good all the time.
Right? It's like there's conditions and they're based on a worldview
and I don't even agree with that worldview. And it's the whole
point of saying it though so other people can respond to it.
It's like a political argument.
It's not even a good political argument. Just respond to it.
Call it stupid. >> country and this is happening in Europe,
too. So, if you're European and you're like, "Oh, this doesn't
apply to me. We don't have this problem." Yeah, you do. They're
driving through the crowds with with trucks instead of guns.
Oh, wow, that's so much better. You guys have problems, too.
This is a problem inside of all of Western civilization because
I think that we have culturally not been willing to just put
our foot down with these freaks, these absolute
deranged, mentally ill, violent
And I It sucks a little bit, okay? Because I
believe a little bit along these lines. I do think that like
the idea of protests forming and the idea of like major social
or civil disruptions
without any cost to them is too much. Like that that can't be
the case. I famously argued that certain people protesting in
a certain place once, okay, hypothetically in a video game we
argued that. It's like, "Okay, I don't think they should be like
arrested,
but like they should have like a broken
Right? Like their radius should get broken. Like a a wrist break,
real quick wrist break, quick, clean. They get a free cast for
it. You have to deal with like some inconvenience. You have to
be inconvenienced and in pain for the right to protest in some
way. Right? To me,
the zero cost, I get to go and up and then I just go back. I
peel back and and head back into society and and there's nothing.
If there's no cost at all, I feel like protesting becomes something
people opt into for not the right reasons. Throw them in jail?
Oh, I'm just of the opinion that throwing people in jail is actually
a higher level of like violation.
And higher likelihood of their rights being revoked. But hey,
if you want to throw them in jail, sure. That costs a lot of
money. Wrist break is real quick. psychotic freaks that need
I I mostly mean like riots and stuff, Dirty Easy. I don't mean
like people, you know, having a picket line, obviously, right?
If you are though, if you're like totally disrupting traffic
for hours and hours on end, I do think that falls into the like
a form of
And I do think there should be a cost to that. And it should
be a cost you're willing to pay. If Hey, if you're protesting
against the right things, if really really horrendous injustices
are being done, should be totally worth it, I'm going to find
it instead. to be put in a mental institution and locked up indefinitely.
And everybody else, by the way, IF WE DID THIS, EVERYBODY WOULD
BE LIVING in paradise. Everything would be great. Everything
would be amazing. Oh, wow, I go to CVS. Oh, I want to buy a candy
bar. Well, let me go speak to the manager's manager so he can
get the special key that was made by uh, you know, the Wizard
of Eyes to open it up for me to get a Reese's Peanut Butter Cups.
Uh, no, I don't think so, guys. And before you say, "Oh, well,
they're stealing because they're poor." Uh, yeah, I'm pretty
sure you can't eat makeup, all right? No, they're not. They're
stealing because they can and
Jeez, he's had a lot of these voice cracks going on recently,
doesn't he?
Again, you can you can fix stuff like this. Like any more expensive
retail
I think there should be again some kind of escalating system
of fines or punishment where if you're doing retail theft over
and over again, you can't just keep breaking the same law over
and over again that you get higher and higher penalties for it.
they're getting away with it. And so, we have a world where we
have enabled and allowed this completely destructive behavior
because people have been mentally guilt-tripped and emotionally
manipulated into thinking that this is somehow the only outcome
that a person can have. "Well, I had things hard as a kid, that
means I steal Kias and I drive them down the highway at 150 miles
an hour. Well, you know what? My dad wasn't around, so that means
I get to burn down the 7-Eleven."
Uh, I don't think so, guys. I don't. And I don't think anybody
else likes this, either. I have what I call the 7-Eleven
Well, hold on. You have to understand, Ramond Davis, that when
people do the defense of
of like criminality on the basis of people need that, then somebody's
going to do the defense of like authoritarian police crackdowns
because he feels people need that, right?
Like both sides of the extreme here are going to be covered.
He hasn't even really said what he wants in terms of policing
yet, either, but absolutely somebody else If you're going to
That is an obvious reaction that you're going to get. That if
you are going to go and say, "I understand why people would steal
and I understand why this would happen and I think we shouldn't
have major punishments for some of these things where we should
try to get away with it," then somebody's going to come out and
go, "Hey, I I think the opposite of
Right? eclair index. Let me explain what that is. We all know
7-Eleven eclairs,
Right? I I I think we all we're Hopefully, I'm not the only fat
piece of [__] here. I'm not fat, I'm trans fat, but
it's the same thing. And you go to you go to 7-Eleven and they
have the eclairs in the little bakery goods thing. Well, I found
that if you want to go late at night and you want to get one
of those eclairs, you have to go to a 7-Eleven that doesn't have
any hobos or anybody around like any of these random Oh, somebody's
talking to their knife. There's not going to be any eclairs in
that 7-Eleven. Let me tell you that. And so, nobody wants to
be around this [__] Nobody wants to deal with this,
but nobody wants to say it because they've created this sort
of like uh, you know, some sort of moral cachet
in complete
Hold on. Nobody Nobody wants to be around it though.
Right? It's just you have wildly different It's basically whether
you want uh, what's the word? Like rehabilitative or punitive
justice for these things existing, right? You want to punish
these people for being homeless and being uh, like I don't know,
loitering around 7-Eleven or you want to try to help them in
some way and try to get them reintegrated back into society.
Like ultimately, there is probably
the problem with the homeless thing, at least in a lot of North
America, is that you're probably not fixing that. Like for a
lot of those people, the reason they're persistently homeless
is is long-term substance abuse or mental illness or both.
And that could take That's very expensive to fix on the individual
level and you get almost nothing back as a society for for fixing
it.
Right? It's like basically your conscience is clear if you don't
have punitive policies for these kinds of things. You fix crimes
prob- crime problems so we have nice things like 7-Eleven donuts.
Well, hold on, Pensive Goat. You could do that. You could just
make it really specific to what he's pointing out.
But that to me is like you're you're basically refusing to have
the argument, right? Now, I Again, somebody said it's restorative
justice. I do think there's like something to that. Ultimately,
I think America's seen this, right? America used to have widespread
asylums, right? And the abuses there were really bad and the
government basically shut them down and couldn't really deal
with them anymore and they have transferred into private care
in the US for the most part. And I don't actually know I don't
think that works and I don't know if the government's ever going
to take on the burden of doing it again. So, I actually don't
know how you solve that problem in America given your total lack
of social
Social funding.
Yeah, I I like realistically, you guys don't even have health
care. I don't know how you're going to get to that. It's but
it it Yeah, you have to house these people. You have to put them
somewhere and has to be somewhere where they're not going to
be significantly
like incentivized to leave and go back to wherever they were
loitering, right? Cuz that's where you get the most hobos is
where people are like making a lot of money, where there's like
high-end areas and they could beg for money, they could beg for
stuff, they can get things from people, right? There's not a
lot of like 40-person towns with a bunch of hobos kicking around.
It's always in big cities and right? You have to figure out some
way that you can create somewhere where they could stay
and they're not just going to go and leave and go back to wherever
they were in the city. Yeah, very complex issue to deal with
the homeless problem. societal dysfunction. And I think that
it's reaching a fever pitch. I think if they ever succeed Oh,
let's say you shoot Trump. Oh, yeah, all your problems are going
to go away now with President J.D. Vance. Yeah, oh, you should
shoot him. Oh, well, now you've got Marco Rubio. It's not going
to work, right? You You're going to have to shoot a lot more
people than that, right? And my opinion on this is let's not
shoot anybody. How about just bring a better candidate next time
and get more of your guys out to vote and maybe something will
happen that's in your favor. But oh, well, we can't do that.
And so, anyway, this is where I think things are going is that
we are reaching a position where there is so much just day-to-day
societal dysfunction. Just average dysfunction. Like you go to
the store.
Like I went to Walmart. I went to Walmart and I went to buy a
pack of underwear. Now, I'm a 35-year-old man. This doesn't embarrass
me anymore because, you know, I've got a few gray hairs. But
if I was 18, I would have been mortified by this. The woman had
to unlock the underwear case, pull out the underwear, and I said,
"Okay, can I have them?" She says, "Yes, you can have them. I
have to walk them up to the register." And of course, you know,
you have like 17 different registers at the Walmart. Oh, I don't
live anywhere like this. This is rough, man. How do you deal
with this? This seems crazy. >> Three of them. No, that's
not true. One of them is open. And so, I have to go there. I'm
sitting in this long line. And she says, "Yeah, he's buying underwear.
These underwear are for him." And it's like, "Oh my god, this
is so it's it's mortifying. It's embarrassing,
Brother, I'm Why would you go to
I don't know why you go to Walmart at that point. It's just Amazon,
right? That's where you go. I get it's probably good he's supporting
big box stores where he lives, right? But, man,
Amazon, dog. >> And again, like it's the kind of thing
that, you know, you get old enough and you just laugh at it.
But,
whenever you're younger, it's ridiculous. And I still laugh at
it, but it's for a different reason. I'm mortified for a different
reason. I'm mortified that I'm living in a minimum security prison.
The entire world is being turned into a minimum security prison
so we can accommodate the bottom 2% of the bad actors in our
society. Everybody has to live in this because we don't want
to put them in it. It drives me crazy. It makes me so angry.
And I think people
Uh you do have to be more accommodating, though. Like I think
the thing the left doesn't understand when it comes to stuff
like homelessness or crime is that
if you are an a boundless fountain of empathy for this problem,
where you will never let anything proceed, or you're always willing
to fight on every single issue, and never let it proceed or get
it fixed at all without it being like purely we're going to just
spend money, invest money to help these people, right? Eventually,
you get somebody like
Oh, what is his name? Not Maduro. Filipino guy.
Uh not not Bong not Bingbing or Bongbong or Bang Bong or Bom
Bom. Not that guy, the other guy, Duterte. Yeah. Dude, Duterte
solved that problem big time. And
like if you talk to people who lived in the Philippines or who
lived in Manila or had family who lived in Manila, holy [__]
You you can't believe how quickly like the more liberal people
who lived in Manila were totally liberal, hated Duterte, and
then were like, "Wait, >> all the homeless people are gone.
Wait, what? Wait, oh wait, all the drug dealers are gone." And
it's like, "Yeah, all it took is Yeah, Marcos is not who I'm
talking about. I'm talking about
I'm just I'm saying that people don't understand that like some
of these things do Yeah, yeah, technically yes. Yes. Like there
obviously there are massive civil rights abuses, but eventually
things can get bad enough that people are very very very okay
with crazy [__] happening, all
You got to be You got to be careful. I think eventually, what's
going to happen is people are there's going to be somebody that
runs for government, somebody that runs for office that says,
"I'm going to stop this." And they will. And it's not going to
be a good thing. And the thing is that and everybody will be
happy for this because you have to remember, I think it was Benjamin
Franklin that said, "The people who desire safety over freedom
deserve neither." Right? Or something some some variation of
that, right? Well, this is the problem with what Benjamin Franklin
said. Back then, they didn't have universal suffrage. Now, they
do. And when everybody can vote, most people are going to choose
safety every single time. So, we have a society of people that
will I think >> What is the argument there? What Does he
understand that the reason you say the universal suffrage thing
is people and put people choose safety? Are you saying that women
voters are going to help you liquidate the homeless? Make the
Soylent Green dream come true?
I don't even know what he What is he trying to say here? He's
like weaving.
No, the way people the way right-wingers describe this is women
always vote for safety. That's why they always vote for like
social policy like like basically increasing social safety nets
and stuff. So, but but that's Is he saying women will vote to
do this? To go hardcore on the homeless? I'd say he's wrong,
but then we all know Anarchist Baryon's journey, and that's that
took a dark path, okay? >> is right. [clears throat] Willingly
and beg for Minority Report. And and not I don't mean reporting
a black person. I mean the movie. I'm talking about somebody
going and actually having
Dude, his jokes are so bad.
Sometimes he We're going to be like Minority Report. And I don't
mean reporting a black person. I mean like the movie.
Bro, what?
and beg for Minority Report. And and not I don't mean reporting
a black person. I mean the movie. I'm talking about somebody
going and actually having uh you know, like databases on them,
like eye tracking. I don't know if you guys have seen this, but
they're now mandating uh you know, cameras in cars now to be
able to detect and turn on and turn off cars at will and be able
to detect things like drowsiness and other types of innervative
driving behavior. So, this is where things are going. And the
problem is that if you have enough drunk driving, and if you
have enough texting and driving, and you have enough of everything
in between, you're going to have people that are asking for that.
And I think that's the world that we're going towards, and I
think this is a very sad thing. I don't want to live in 1984.
I don't want to live in I mean, honestly, in some cases, and
I think a lot of people like I was just saying, I don't want
to live in China. Bro, I have yet to see an authoritarian measure
that's been put into place in the American government that Asmongold
hasn't squealed for. Enjoy, obviously.
What are we talking about? I don't want to live in 1984? Are
you sure? I feel like that's your ideal society, isn't it? I
feel like that's what you've been describing, no? I know. But
then I'm thinking to myself, "Well, if you look at Dubai, if
you look at China, you look at Singapore, and you look at El
Salvador now, you you go go go Google Maps. Go Google Maps."
And I'm not saying everywhere, but many of these places, they're
very nice, and there's not [__] everywhere, and there
aren't a bunch of people sitting around uh you know, having a
fire with um plastic and tires. And so, this isn't happening,
and they're like passed out like fentanyl. All right, dude, the
Singapore thing is kind of crazy. I do wonder if if America will
finally adopt something like that. You know what I mean? Like
Singapore, from what I understand, is like archaic with the way
they punish crime, no? Like literally any social violation, you're
looking at jail time potentially. Aren't they like crazy? And
then aren't the jails also like disgusting?
No, I don't mean like they're abusive, although they probably
are. I just mean like you could go to jail over like nothing.
You can
get fined over nothing. Anyway, we keep >> zombie. And
so, I think that what's happening is that this is either a colossal
amount of Almost like China builds a of housing. Wait. Do we
have to find a video on how China deals with their homeless problem
if there is such a problem? Cuz they build a of housing, but
most people in China own more than one property. So, I'm guessing
they have a homeless problem, and I'm guessing the way they deal
with it is not, "Here, have a
Right? It's definitely not, "Here, have a house." It's going
to be something like I saw during COVID, they had a lot of homeless
cats, and those cats went in some bags, and I said I I tend to
believe that those bags either went in a river or into an incinerator,
okay? I don't think those bags full of cats went out and like
they were put out free free range somewhere, right?
of mismanagement that is so bad that it will be seen historically
as like an age of decline, or it is being done intentionally.
This dysfunction, this unrest, all these problems are being done
intentionally so they can manifest the reality of the next police
state. The Patriot Act 2. You know, do you do you want to be
texting your friend, and then you make a joke, and it's about
something blowing something up, and then immediately you have
the police coming, and they're shutting down your service because
it's been AI parsed, and they have like a complete apparatus,
and they're using telemetry, and they're trying to figure out,
"Well, wait a minute. This guy, I think he's the one. This could
be Al-Qaeda. He could be radicalized. It could be one of those
incels with a bomb." And then before you know it, you're on a
list, and you can't use an airplane. And no, I don't want to
be in that world. I don't want to live in that world. It's ridiculous.
But, the problem is that because we're not taking the reasonable
countermeasures to solve this, I think that the only outcome
is that we will have an unreasonable consequence for not solving
it. >> What Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. HOLD ON. HOLD ON.
WAIT, what are the reasonable I haven't even heard one of his
solutions yet. What's the reasonable countermeasure? What reasonable
countermeasure is everybody ignoring? Hold on.
Yeah. Wait, Asmongold, now you're cooking. Tell me what your
reasonable countermeasures are. >> extreme lengths. Fundamentally,
this type of lifestyle cannot continue. This level of dysfunction
cannot continue. You can't have people that are just stealing
things wantonly out of every store. Stores are going to be closing,
and they already do. And then what happens when that happens?
Well, people lose their jobs. What happens when they lose their
jobs? Well, they're stealing from the remaining stores. So, then
the remaining You see how this happens? You see, this is the
third worldism that I'm talking about. We can't live in this
world. This isn't going to work. And so, my plea and my ask for
so many people, and these are people in the government, people
that listen to me, and everybody, is that please stop allowing
our culture to be colonized by absolute savages. Why are we allowing
our society This isn't your culture being culture being uh Dude,
he's just totally wrong on this. All those countries where Listen,
any country where you're coming from that has really really low
or that like you're talking about all these immigrants who would
come to America. This is American culture, right? The the possible
reeducation stuff, the acceptance and and or not over punishment
of crimes, that's American culture, that's Western culture.
All the all the savage places Asmongold's describing have the
most archaic, most hardcore punishments for
That's where all those people are coming
What are we talking about? That's not It's not being imported,
it was just here. There could be something culturally that's
causing and I I mean I assume it's the lack of economic opportunity
most more than anything, but it it could be something culturally
now that's causing it, but I I don't think it's anything imported.
This is just America not standing up to the change in in standards
of living for all of the people. Like the Ameri- the existing
American culture is not standing up well.
That's what it seems like to me. themselves to be totally ruled
over by the bottom 2% of people that should be locked in a box
for the rest of their life, at least. And this is the thing.
I think that this is the most reasonable and the most uh like
acceptable way to do this. And the reason why is because if we
don't have that, those people rule over you. They rule over you.
I don't think you're going to have some big mass uh you know,
class awakening. You're not going to have the communist revolution.
No, if if worst-case scenario, the rich people will pay half
the poor people to kill the other half. So, I'm not really getting
excited I do think that's where it's going though, a little bit.
It I Honest to god, that feels like
At what point do you not have like mass unemployment and then
what do you actually employ humans for? Well, private militias
to deal with the other to deal with like the people who would
come to [__] with you. That's to me where things
are going if the economy's not reoriented in some way. Is like
honest to god, what Asmongold just said there is actually pertinent
to me. That's actually where I see it going if there's not any
sort of reorganization at all. Is eventually people are going
to be There's going to be if AI takes off at all, mass unemployment,
right? There will be. And then what do you do to protect yourself
as a rich person against the people who might come to [__]
with you? I always see all these people on TikTok and stuff like
that. I get this stuff sent to me. And they're saying, "Well,
I can't wait for the revolution." And somebody has a you know,
like a a 9 mm gun and a Kevlar vest that they got off of Temu.
Oh, yeah. You're definitely ready for the revolution, buddy.
So, we have this overwhelming just sense of just complete hubris
and bravado that people have on these social media apps. Like
this is going to be anything other than a complete crime against
humanity. And all I'm saying is that I would rather this problem
be a page in the history books instead of an entire chapter.
And I think we're moving towards the chapter. Please, can we
please just
Can we get these crazy people under control before we all have
to be under control? Can we please do this? And I had to make
a video and talk about this because it's outrageous. It's absolutely
outrageous what's going on and how we've allowed this to happen.
And I I want to make this This is a plea to everybody. And this
is This is a I still haven't heard a recommendation.
I literally haven't heard a single He said there was obvious,
very clear and obvious like simple solutions. I've not heard
a single one yet. Where the [__] are these Asmongold?
Where the [__] are the solutions? Give me a suggestion.
I love ideas, man. A very important value system that I have
Said mass arrest multiple times. Yeah, but he's arguing for like
Hasan to be arrested and anybody who's called for violence in
any way, and he's not applying it to himself.
So, I don't even know where that line is. You If you want to
do mass arrest, you got to propose a law. Where's the law? Don't
just point at people you dislike and say arrest those people.
Give me the rule for society
That's what you got to do. You can't just point at people and
say, "Well, I don't like that. I don't like that. I don't like
that."
That's That's brainless.